foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory
the Headmasters of Hogwarts were some of
the most interesting Wizards and witches
in the world some were expert potioneers
some were Lightning Fast Duelists and
some even were experts on dark magic who
were they and what did they contribute
to the Hogwarts Legacy we'll answer
these questions and More in today's
video number one first Headmaster of
Hogwarts although Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry was founded in
990 A.D it didn't start with a
Headmaster at that time the four
co-founders godra Gryffindor Rowena
ravencore Helga Hufflepuff and Salazar
Southern oversawed the school's
Administration but by the following
Century that changed as well as us that
they're in departed leaving the
management of his house in disarray it
was likely during the aftermath of
Sutherland's untimely self-exile that
the other aging co-founders hired
someone to help run the school this was
the first Headmaster of Hogwarts but
unfortunately we don't know much about
him All That Remains the golden brass
statue that was molded in his honor 2.
Brian gagwild the next Headmaster to
show up in historical Records Was a
professor by the name of Brian gagwild
in his portrait which hangs inside
Hogwarts headmaster's office shows that
gag Wilde was a particularly unique
looking wizard he wore a bright orange
ConEd cap a bright green tunic and a
maroon scarf he was likely born in
England although Scotland and Ireland
also produced many of the professors who
would later work at Hogwarts gagwan's
lasting contribution to the Wizarding
World was a book published by Luca books
called chicory pokery and Hocus Pocus a
textbook that focused on mischievous
spells
3. heliotrope Wilkins presumably the
next Headmaster of Hogwart was a wedge
named heliotrope Wilkins her impact on
the Wizarding World was even less than
Brian gagwilds as they had mistress
heliotrope continued Hogwarts strong
tradition of treating witches and
wizards equally which contrasted quite a
bit with the Muggle world of the time 4.
philadelpore was a noble woman and had
Mistress of Hogwarts sometime in the
1400s she wore a striking gold brooch
with a dark purple stone gem nestled
inside with her long black hair and
iconic dark mole she bore a striking
resemblance to a later Hogwarts and
master Severus Snape ball was quite an
active academic and produced a textbook
for herbology class titled 1000 magical
herbs and fungi
5. Odessa second Denberg the next
Headmaster appears in the 1500s edessa
second Denberg a headmistress of British
Heritage served Hogwarts for a few
decades during that Century According to
some reports edessa contributed a great
deal to textbooks on Michael history and
if you take one look at her portrait you
can see that she was quite an imposing
witch and possibly a skilled potions
Master 6. fiddly under Cliff fiddly
Undercliff was another Headmaster of the
16th century with a massive Whitebeard a
tool wizard's hat and a dark brown staff
thitherly looks every bit the part of a
medieval wizard during his time as
Headmaster he often sported ornate rings
on his hands and a golden chain that
held a series of rings on its end we
can't be sure if these were powerful
magical relics or simple heirlooms but
it's entirely possible that they
possessed some intrinsic magical
properties
bitterly also had a strange connection
with Christian angels on his portrait at
Hogwarts the order of all eight Angels
were written above His image
7. Antonia chrisworthy Antonia
chrisworthy was a witch born in 1609 who
lived for nearly 200 years at some point
in her lengthy life Antonia became a
professor and then had mistress at
Hogwarts Antonia like edessa before her
was also a noble woman she has no
textbooks credited to her name but she
often was a great source of ancient news
and gossip when students sought old
daily Prophet stories Antonia's portrait
was able to recite the news as if it
were only yesterday
8. Elizabeth Burke Elizabeth Burke is
the next headmistress that appears in
historical records even though her time
as an administrator at Hogwarts wasn't
particularly memorable Berks left quite
a mark on Harry Potter's peers
her portrait which rotated around the
school each year often shouted about the
superiority of pure Bloods and the
Excellence of Slytherin students 9.
Gifford Abbott Gifford Abbott was a
British wizard former Hogwarts student
and former Headmaster of the school
sometime after Burke and chrisworthy's
tenure in his portrait he's shown
alongside a high-shouldered Hound which
was strangely unique for Headmasters
they were rarely depicted with pets so
Abbott must have been a dog Enthusiast
during his life
when he was initially sorted by the
Sorting Hat he was placed into
Hufflepuff making him one of the rare
Headmasters to graduate from that house
10. volpus volpus is the next Headmaster
listed in historical records but just
like so many others not much is known
about the deceased Wizard and when we
turn to his portraits we're left with
even more questions than when we started
as volpus's vampiric appearance makes us
wonder if he was afflicted with any
magical maladies 11. vindictus Viridian
thankfully the next Headmaster our list
vindictus Viridian achieved a great deal
during his life so we'll have a lot to
talk about according to historian's best
guesses Viridian was born sometime in
the 17th century and might have joined
her Court staff during the 1800s as a
teacher he became quite skilled at
potion making and used that talent to
instruct children at Hogwarts he was
also quite the writer during his time in
Academia he created an odd little book
one that would have been more at home
and Harpo The fowl's home rather than
the headmaster's office the book was
titled curses into counter curses
bewitch your friends and befuddle your
enemies with the latest revenges hair
loss jelly legs tongue tying and much
much more the text must have made him
popular among students who never seemed
to relent in teasing their peers 12.
amro's SWAT sometime later amro's SWAT
was listed as another Headmaster at
Hogwarts unfortunately SWAT must have
lived an uninteresting life because he
barely fills a page in the histories but
there is one interesting tidbit to take
from Swant on his portrait the phrase
Aura elabora is inscribed that line
taken from the Benedictine monks of the
Middle Ages meant that simply sitting
around and praying or studying could
never replace good honest work
with such a practical mindset it
wouldn't surprise me if amro's SWAT was
a popular Headmaster amongst the
students of the era 13. Dillis Derwent
Dillis Derwent was a powerful magical
healer and an employee of Saint mungo's
Hospital for Magical Melodies and
injuries eventually she went on to
become a headmistress at Hogwarts
although her career path wasn't the most
conventional one Derwent was quite a
success her students and the other
faculty members at the school were
enamored with derwins so much so that
even during Harry Potter's time at
Hogwarts Derwent was fondly remembered
as one of the greatest teachers the
school had ever had and since Hogwarts
didn't really provide the most accurate
dates Dallas Derwent might have actually
predated some of the other Wizards on
this list According to some she died in
the mid to late 18th century
14. everard had Master everard just like
dilis was another much beloved
Headmaster from Hogwarts history just
like the other members of this list
we're not really certain when he lived
but if you take a look at his portrait
the clothes that he wears give us a few
hints based on his style of hat and coat
he probably served as a Headmaster
sometime in the late 1700s to mid-1800s
15. eupraxia mole eupraxia mole became
the headmistress of Hogwarts sometime in
the late 1800s as they had mistress
during the mughals second era of
industrialization eupraxia stood as a
symbolic break against the storm of
Technology although much of the
Wizarding World remained oblivious it
would only be a matter of time before
the devices the Muggles created during
this era would come to affect the World
At Large
16. Quentin Trimble Quentin Trimble was
the Headmaster of Hogwarts sometime
after eupraxia mole as a member of
Hogwarts faculty Quentin was renowned
for his knowledge of dark magic and he
even penned the text the dark Forces a
guide to self-protection that book
became the basis for all future defense
against the dark arts classes 17.
limbert another Headmaster of the era
was simply known as Professor limbert
unfortunately he doesn't have any
textbooks credited to his name so we
don't know much about him based on his
portrait he might have actually been
fairly Young when he took on the role of
Headmaster but that is the only
interesting tidbit that we could guess
at 18. Dexter Fortescue Dexter Fortescue
was a Headmaster during the same era and
just like limbert his time at Hogwarts
is a great mystery but luckily for us
one of Dexter's ascendants lived during
Harry's time at school his name was
Florian Fortescue and he owned a famous
ice cream shop alongside the other
magical stores in Diagon Alley as a
store owner Florian was a kind-hearted
soul and even tended to Harry at times
before Lord Voldemort had the shop owner
killed 19. basil franzak basil franzak
was a Headmaster at Hogwarts during the
19th century and interestingly there's a
striking resemblance to Professor
Dumbledore with half moon spectacles a
long Gray beard and a tall black cat
basil looks like a quintessential old
kind wizard
basil studied in Ravenclaw when he was a
student at Hogwarts and as a Headmaster
favored that house whenever an issue
arose 20. Walter Aragon Walter Aragon
was Headmaster of Hogwarts during the
late 19th early 20th century but while
becoming Headmaster of Hogwarts is an
achievement of Epic Proportions that
certainly wasn't all that arrogant a
very driven wizard was able to achieve
in his lifetime in fact Aragon a clear
academic was also a published author and
chess champion his interest in the care
of magical creatures led him to
authoring a book entitled newts of
bognor and his love for chess meant that
he would eventually have a chess
competition named after him Walter died
before 1943 but after his death his
portrait was hung at the grand staircase
as well as inside the headmaster's
office 21 modicus Ang there is a
portrait of a man named mordika
headmaster's office but we don't know if
it's the same mordecas AG we have
information on from Canon it's entirely
possible that Headmaster Monica zag was
an entirely different mordec than the
one I'm about to discuss Monica's egg as
we know him was a wizard in Hogwarts
resident muggle expert going on to
author the philosophy of the mundane why
the Muggles prefer not to know and
cooking the Muggle way provided that
this monarchist was at Hogwarts as late
as 1993. it's unlikely that he is the
same motocus who once acted as
Headmaster but that's still unclear
unless AG was exceptionally old I don't
see how he could have served as
Headmaster in a time period that isn't
already spoken for my other Headmasters
22. Brutus scrimger Brutus scrimga who
was more than likely a distant relative
of Rufus scrimga served as Headmaster of
Hogwarts during the 19th or 20th century
dates are unclear scrim girl was known
to have been a huge quidditch fan with
quidditch even becoming a part of his
legacy going on to write the beta's
Bible it's likely that scrim girl was a
beat himself at one point at least I'd
hope so scrimgo was immortalized in the
form of several portraits hung
throughout Hogwarts Castle one portrait
which was hung in the Hogwarts trophy
room had a secret passage to the fourth
floor opened by the password BT pacifici
another of his portraits was hung in the
headmaster's office
23. Phineas nigellous black Phineas
nigellus black of the infamous House of
black was born in 1847 and it became one
of the most influential members of the
family to ever live as most blacks would
Phineas attended Hogwarts and once of
course placed into house Slytherin
Phineas was also very vocal in carrying
on another family tradition his hatred
for Muggle and mud Bloods after he
graduated from Hogwarts around the year
1865 Phineas married Ursula Flint
together they had five children when he
wasn't conceiving children Phineas
became a professional teacher passing on
all that he had learned the next
generation of wizards and witches his
talent eventually pulled him to Hogwarts
but it's hard to know how effective he
was as a teacher when it comes to
Black's teaching style the record books
simply point out that he hated his job
and he hated the children that didn't
stop him from achieving success though
as he eventually Rose to the position of
Headmaster Phineas nigellus black went
down in history as the least liked
master that Hogwarts ever had at least
according to his great-great-grandson
Sirius 24. Armando dipit Armando dipit
Dumbledore's predecessor as Headmaster
was born in the year 1637 and lived to
the Staggering age of 355 making him one
of the oldest Wizards in Wizarding
history according to Dumbledore when
dippit left the position between 1965
and 1971 he was nearly bald and somewhat
feeble for 355 I'd certainly hope so
dippit served as Headmaster for a few
decades starting somewhere between 1940
and remaining in the position until
possibly the early 70s dipit can be
easily remembered as the serving and
master during Tom Riddle's time at the
school the same time that the Chamber of
Secrets was being opened and students
were being attacked dipit was also
infamously responsible for the expulsion
of rubius Hagrid after his death dip it
much like other Headmasters was
immortalized in a portrait hung inside
the headmaster's office 25. Albus
Dumbledore the man that needs no
introduction Dumbledore was in my
opinion the greatest Headmaster to you
ever hold the title he served with
distinction from 1971 to 1997 with a few
little hiccups and suspensions along the
way but during those years he made a
considerable impact on some of the most
important students and staff that would
ever exist in the Wizarding World El
fias Doge put it best Albus Dumbledore
was ever proud or vain he could find
something to value in anyone however
apparently insignificant or wretched and
I believe that his early losses endowed
him with great humanity and sympathy 26.
Dolores Umbridge in 1995 disaster struck
Hogwarts before you see it was this year
that Umbridge was appointed as the new
defense against the dark arts Professor
Umbridge was a poor teacher mainly
because she taught her own biased and
ineffective curriculum however she
didn't act in this role alone for long
as she was eventually appointed as
Hogwarts first ever high Inquisitor a
position that she used to harass
students and peers however this power
still wasn't enough for Umbridge as
Dumbledore was still technically in
charge he was Headmaster during this
time the ministry namely fudge and
Dumbledore were continually butting
hands the fight was lashing out he was
blinded by fear and in utter denial that
the Dark Lord Voldemort had returned
Dumbledore continually tried to convince
verge of the truth but his efforts were
futile and fudge continued to punish
Dumbledore in whatever way he could
eventually Dolores Umbridge and her
inquisitorial Squad discovered the
headquarters of Dumbledore's Army in the
room of requirement Dumbledore's Army
was of course formed by Harry and had
nothing to do with Dumbledore but with
Dumbledore's name in the group's name
fingers started to get pointed at him
Dumbledore happily took responsibility
for the formation of the group claiming
that it was all his idea and that no
student should be punished in his place
after a minor scuffle with Umbridge some
auras and find Dumbledore eventually
left her Goods this left the school
without a Headmaster at this point
Umbridge passed educational decree
number 28 which effectively replaced
Dumbledore with umbrage
Umbridge was headmistress of Hogwarts
however when irrefutable evidence came
to light pointing to Voldemort's return
Dumbledore was reappointed as Headmaster
and much to the joy of the Hogwarts
population
Umbridge no longer had anything to do
with the school 27. Severus Snape
Severus Snape served as Headmaster
during the 97-98 school year it was a
dark time Dumbledore had just died
Voldemort and his Death Eaters had taken
over Hogwarts and the ministry
muggleborns weren't allowed to attend
Hogwarts and students were being
punished with unforgivable curses what a
Time Snape's brawler said Master ended
when Harry Hermione and Ron who would
return to the school rallied the
students and staff against Snape and his
new cohort a jewel then erupted between
Snape and McGonagall with Snape
eventually jumping out of a classroom
window Snape was still acting as a
double agent at this time and I don't
expect that he would have wanted to hurt
anyone so fleeing was probably the best
option 28 Minerva McGonagall Minerva
McGonagall served as the Transfiguration
professor of Hogwarts for many years
also acting as stand-in Headmaster
during Dumbledore's
um suspensions after Dumbledore's death
McGonagall served had Master Severus
Snape who had been appointed by
Voldemort and the Death Eaters however
after Snape had been effectively ousted
from the school McGonagall took over the
position after the war had ended
McGonagall was offered the order of
Merlin First Class by the new Minister
for magic Kingsley shacklebold and just
four short months after that McGonagall
who was more suitable for the role than
anyone was properly appointed as the new
Hogwarts admistress McGonagall presided
over Court students beginning with the
1998 to 1999 school year and after her
promotion moved into Dumbledore's old
quarters as she had given up her
Transfiguration posting she was now
responsible for among other things
finding her replacement you might also
remember that McGonagall served as a
special messenger for Hogwarts and would
travel to the homes of prospective
muggle-born students and inform their
families of their child's magical
abilities this task was eventually
handed off to rubius Hagrid which is
questionable given his immense size and
initial shock value and that's it for
this video did you know about all of
these Headmasters which were new names
for you leave a comment down below until
next time remember it does not do to
dwell on dreams and forgets and to live
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]